Tenir des baguettes, c'est un peu comme tenir un stylo
sauf que vous en avez deux
et que vous les pincez ensemble.
La plupart sont en bois. On en fabrique aussi en plastique, bambou,
jade, or, argent et même en ivoire,
même si c'est plus trop dans l'air du temps.
Les baguettes sont conçues pour manger de petits morceaux de nourriture.
On peut saisir des nouilles,
manger du riz si on est habile,
saisir des raviolis, des bouts de viande.
Il y a des choses qui ne se font pas avec les baguettes,
comme s'en servir pour faire de la batterie,
même si c'est tentant.
Il est mal vu de planter les baguettes verticalement dans un bol de riz
parce que cela fait penser à un bol d'encens,
ce qui évoque la mort.
Les baguettes sont très répandues dans le monde,
dans une grande partie de l'Asie, environ un milliard et demi
de personnes les utilisent.
Chaque culture possède une version légèrement différente des baguettes.
Les baguettes chinoises sont plutôt longues et arrondies.
Les baguettes coréennes sont plus plates et souvent en métal
et les baguettes japonaises
ont tendance à être arrondies et très, très pointues.
Bien que les baguettes se soient banalisées
dans la société américaine,
il fut un temps, à la fin du 19ème siècle
où les Asiatiques,
parce qu'ils mangeaient du riz avec des baguettes,
avaient un statut différent des Américains,
qui mangeaient de la viande
avec une fourchette et un couteau.
Mais quand la Chine et les États-Unis
ont commencé à nouer des liens diplomatiques dans les années 70
Richard Nixon, Henry Kissinger,
ont dû s'exercer à manger avec des baguettes.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'au moment où la cuisine asiatique s'est déplacée de l'est vers l'ouest,
les baguettes ont été intégrées au mouvement.
On a retrouvé des baguettes datant de la dynastie Shang
il y a environ 3 000 ans.
Les trépieds étaient très populaires pendant la dynastie Shang.
Quand on cuisinait avec ces grands trépieds,
les baguettes étaient très utiles
car elles permettaient de mélanger et d'attraper
sans se brûler quand on faisait bouillir de l'eau
dans ces grandes marmites.
Couteaux et fourchettes sont présents
dans la culture chinoise, on les utilise souvent pour cuisiner.
Mais ce qui a été transposé dans la salle à manger,
ce sont les baguettes.
Une particularité de la cuisine asiatique
est qu'elle est souvent servie en petits morceaux.
Je pense que c'est en partie dû au fait
que l'on consomme moins d'énergie
en faisant cuire des petits morceaux rapidement.
Et l'on a pas besoin de les couper.
Il y a une influence circulaire
entre le type d'aliment qui doit permettre l'utilisation de baguettes,
et le fait d'avoir des baguettes sur le type d'aliment à cuisiner.
Mais les baguettes reflètent aussi la nature communautaire du repas.
Les plats sont disposés au milieu de la table. C'est très familial.
Chacun attrape avec ses baguettes,
se sert sur son riz,
puis mange de son côté.
Il a une légende populaire
qui dit que tout le monde reçoit de longues baguettes,
du genre vraiment trop longues pour se nourrir.
En enfer, on meurt de faim
parce qu'on arrive pas à se mettre de la nourriture dans la bouche.
Alors qu'au paradis, on s'en sert
pour se nourrir les uns les autres.